[Applaudissements]
cela comprend le jingle mais j'ai bien
kiffé bienvenue si rooney sur le plateau
d'à prendre ou à laisser et présenté par
julien courbet et s'adresse à l'huissier
de justice
regardez bien et regarder ce qui va se
passer après alors bon courage et
surtout julien ne sais pas ce qu'il a
dans les boîtes mais je lui ai dit vous
allez passer une bonne soirée commence à
peine à jette vivo lui ai demandé alors
à battre a dit c'est quoi la suite
julien courbet va regretter d'avoir posé
cette question lui si pas mal prendre
une vanne et quitter le plateau où
julien d'instituer la femme en lui
offrant un bouquet de 12 fenêtres en pvc
bien c'est pas grave c'est programmé la
jeune fille vous devez demander
eh bien écoutez je vais demander parce
que c'est ma fille un fardeau
[Rires]
avez vous une grosse gaffe
oui j'ai joué c'est vrai hip hop est
valorisée je sors pas mal en soirée et
j'aurai à lyon en avion
ouais et j'en vois tous les charmantes
jeunes femmes est un sacré bon ça toutes
mes félicitations mais on vraiment moi
et me dit je ne suis pas enceinte
on aurait dû s'arrêter lors d'un mariage
comme le veut la tradition la mariée on
voit le bouquet regarde y'a une pote
qu'il apporte donc un problème alors le
bouquet va s'accrocher aux lustres ouais
une femme va risquer sa vie pour
l'attraper ou benjamin castaldi va
annoncer à la marine oui forcément
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on voit bien que les connaît bien et
d'ailleurs elle s'est mariée à la toile
regardait les jeunes footballeuses qui
jongle dans un gymnase regarde alors pas
mal ce qui va se passer
elle va tirer sur le plafond qui va
s'écrouler elle va s'énerver ou yoann
gourcuf ventre et se blesser en ouvrant
la porte du miroir
ak ce miroir pour témoin qui a gardé
ouais parce qu'il est bien
[Musique]
ah non mais tu avec sa fiancée sur un
pont pour une demande en mariage
d'ailleurs comment vous allez demander
votre femme en mariage le garde pour moi
mais c'était très beau c'est vrai ouais
et benjamin témoin au mariage
il a fait envoyer ainsi la dernière a
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
été un peu plus rapide que toi
à la prochaine ag pas la prochaine fois
sur sa spéciale gaffe
alors non ça s'est fait tout
naturellement au moment où tu m'épouser
on amour que j'aime et comment où et
comment au match de foot à paris alors
on n'est pas gps à auchan ben non non
aux gens des choses à voir aux
chandelles avec kad et o oui bon bah
c'est surtout c'est une boîte on va à
dire prêter moi tu es sur l'iss et
sachez que trop de lumière
[Rires]
c'était un pari très fort mais si nous
n'y ait pas de scénario reste chez toi
que chez moi chez moi chez moi joli car
tu te souviens pas dans dans la tasse
nature une demande alors comment pas
demandé son avis au mariage terre
d'islam en moi comme ça ça parle à tout
le monde avant l'heure je crois que
c'était à portbail bombal alors pour
nice et dans la manche d'accord la plage
au coucher de soleil est avec vous a dit
à côté d'un mariage à l'effet rémanent
ils sont pourris deuxième l'avesnois
week-end à dunkerque butin
très beau vainqueur we can l'agent
makassed a dit qu'en week end à mexico
et vous qu'on traite les villes j'aime
pas contre l'arrivée non c'est bon c'est
pas glam voyage où c'était dans un arrêt
que vous envoyez des boulets et c'est un
petit week end romantique dans un an
un hôtel qui était un vieux moulin c'est
absolument ravissant vieux moulin il a
pas dû payer cher les noms et on a dîné
dans un restaurant très très élégant
très chic surtout les deux voies là et
quand on est rentré dans la chambre en
fait au moment où je suis allé dans la
vieille chanson aussi par son tu veux
mon 10e la journée avait été extrêmement
romantique et le soir lorsque je suis
arrivé sur l'oreiller était posée une
petite boîte à rythme et j'ai ouvert il
y avait la bague est maintenant
d'ailleurs en parlant de baggy et par la
bac tu serais payé les rares et cela au
bout de deux ans oui alors vous comment
s'est passée dans quelques mois c'est
vrai un concert de jane et 6 à lyon je
devrais les désistait les élus avaient
accompagné pour lui faire plaisir a fait
nettoyer ma pause et lui a posé la
question et comme y avait des bruits
qu'elle est sourde oiseaux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
deux frères chaque saison ça prouve que
tu peux te la même question
bah c'est lui c'est pas moi à cette note
n'est pas gros mais si c'est le cas la
trilogie ajouté parce qu'ils avaient dû
mouiller oui mais aussi vous deviez
faire une demande en mariage vous le
feriez comment ah oui ça c'est une bonne
question sahraouie à j'attends la
réponse à venir tu dirais à ma femme
waouh à notre halle où un autre cas du
sultan pas l'avenir raison plaie qu'est
ce que tu tirais chéries chéris
j'assume femme à barbe j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi
j'ai quelque chose à te dire au matin là
se passe bah ça fait longtemps que je
vais dire ce que je pensais de tours ah
voilà j'ai le trac chéri j'ai un message
plutôt à enlever moi cette musique de
merde
quelque chose à te dire quoi je joue
moins bien que toi c'est ça c'est bien
possible mais surtout garder une morte à
bing bac
[Applaudissements]
de toutes les situations
mais une autre source de toutes les
situations
je voulais dire la c3 mode d'art car je
vous dire j'en ai à ras la casquette moi
j'arrive plus à dire cependant ferrari à
nantes avec sa fiancée sur un pont pour
une demande en mariage justement c'est
pour ça qu'on avait fait de mon home and
away perdu le fil de cette
[Musique]
ah la la
alors quand il se passer la bague va
malencontreusement disparaît leproux va
s'écrouler où ça tout va venir prendre
la bac pour agrandir sa colère je prends
ça joue bien on l'aura d'ailleurs pas
tout j'adore fatou non sorciers avec à
la même caractère que moi ah ouais ouais
ça caractère non elle adore les bijoux
elle va trop de zèle du parquet sont
bien oui dans l'eau est partout elle et
marécages
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le gars qui m'a dit me voilà plein gare
menuisier ou side mais on a la preuve
que c'est pas un gag parce que l'ami qui
cadrent ça y est enfin à la fed avait
volé retrouvé pour tous vient d'en faire
une question bague
ah non mais lui c'est le fils de decaux
et ara aprikian maintenant que vous avez
acheté une bague de merde c'est un bon
plan ont fait la fête tombe et htts une
suberbe helmand belle bague
désolé mais deux accrochages d'ancêtres
à méditer n'aurait peut être pas mal
l'aurait fait pas mal d'autres fois
voilà il a accroché d'arrivée oui vous
vous oui pas je travaillais dans une
enseigne de prêt-à-porter de luxe c'est
pas vrai laquelle oui je peux le dire la
sonde en donnera d'autres souvenirs à
kehl et baden également d'autres meubles
prêt-à-porter de luxe qui habille bien
sûr chienne l'époque ça va l'amour est
également newman et monsieur de toujours
ça la griffe de l'homme merci en fait
j'avais mon collègue au rez de chaussée
moi je te première étage et en fait on
peut envoyer par mail des gens qui ont
des animaux qui ressemble à la patronne
à madame sonia rykiel
un jour je me suis trompé j'ai répondu à
un mail commun de la direction et on
écrivait sur la photo bonjour salut moi
c'est sonia ou des trucs comme ça afin
d'être rigolo est en fait un jour un
matin j'ai envoyé le mail à toute la
direction
et bah ça a bardé en plein ébat giberti
pas le grave est là et puis je suis là
voilà ravis fameux c'est vrai fait virer
non je me suis pas fait virer
mais enfin ce n'était pas cool séjour
bien mais juste j'aimerais bien faire
une soirée avec vous et mattingly vous
devez avoir des années
[Rires]
les frères d'amendé comme ça tu bois le
paraguay pour toi c'est quoi ça me suis
à boiser la main sur deux conneries en
terme d'image
on est sur le plateau d'attention à la
marche avec jean luc adam temps c'était
ya quelques années mais attention la
marche nordique nelly dirige maintenant
si les douze coups de pattes une
émission média vous connaissez la télé
c'est beau hein
à votre avis la suite c'est quoi
regardez la plus folle que vous ayez
fait si je le dis là dessus et puis j'ai
proviseur du lycée qu'il a et la tête de
poursuivre le proviseur du lycée mais on
a cassé le lavabo des toilettes du
bâtiment c ne veut pas voir elles n'ont
aucun moment entravé la suite c'est quoi
c'est la police va perdre la mémoire
le mari va tomber dans les pommes ou le
proviseur va débarquer du maître deux
heures de colle et a perdu la mémoire
celle qui ce sont des personnes réelles
avec lui c'est possible qu'il n'y ait
pas la bonne proposition
bravo vous êtes observateurs regardent
et la dispo revoir
[Musique]
sûrement comment c'était
[Applaudissements]
vous aurez bien sûr reconnu la fille
castaldi
[Applaudissements]